zunächst mal ist es eine zahl die für
ganz deutschland gilt und das ist eine
durchschnittszahl und wir sehen jetzt
auch wir haben jetzt 62
und es gibt ja auch jetzt schon
landkreisen bereiche die schon unter 50
sind und es gibt viele lieder über 50
sind das heißt also diese zahl muss man
sehr stark auch immer klar in dem
biografischen kontext sind und es ist
eben eine kennzahl aber wir haben ja
immer gesagt dass es auch eine menge von
anderen kennzahlen gibt die wir beachten
ist und diese instanz ist halt die zahl
die sich am schnellsten ändert das heißt
also ist eine gute kennzahl wo man
schnell eskalieren sollte wenn man also
sieht die tendenz geht hoch dann muss
man schnell reagieren wenn man über
deeskalation spricht also darüber dass
man quasi hier und dort lockern möchte
dann ist die 10 cds zahl nicht die beste
zahl sondern gibt es andere parameter
wie ein bisschen besser geeignet sind
zum beispiel die belegungszahlen der
intensivbetten weil die ja in der regel
etwa zwei wochen den krankheits
infektionsfälle hinterherläuft zwei drei
wochen
das heißt also es ist immer die eine
zahl die im vordergrund bislang steht
aber natürlich betrachten die menschen
auch andere zahlen aber sie brauchen
einen indikator ein richtwert und in dem
bereich bewegt man sich dann ich die
wissen dass ich das unterschrieben habe
dass die publikation von frau briesemann
was kann ich genau das war die
unterschrieben haben obwohl frisuren
mitbeteiligt waren da steht drin ins
elend von zehn habe ich auch schon lange
vor zwei wochen gesagt dass wir eine
coole zahl weil wir davon ausgehen wenn
wir zehn haben dann haben wir 830 fälle
pro tag und ich hatte schon im frühjahr
gesagt dass das eine zahl ist wo wir
wirklich gut regulieren können und und
das geschehen kontrollieren können und
da hat sich meine einschätzung nicht
geändert ich denke dass inzwischen
wahrscheinlich sogar viele
gesundheitsämter auch was mehr noch
können die im aufgebot haben an personal
und auch digital
aber das ist eine zahl mit der könnten
wir super kontrollieren und das ist ja
wirklich wichtig
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren